[Music]  do you need sand but don't know where to  get it I've got it at sand land the  world's greatest sand store where it's  time to go to the beach I do every week  I load up my car with sweet sweets and I  pass the savings on to you hi I have  some relatives visiting from Egypt and I  want them to feel at home here's some  sand W dollars you're a lifesaver  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  I told my wife I was at the beach but I  was actually cheating on it  can you put some sand in my shoes can i  how much does a divorce cost way more  than sand that's for sure  save your marriage at sand land good  stuff do you know what I can get some  ice no ice is the opposite of sand I  don't know about it don't you understand  so call me today I'm the man with the  same  and plan it's a sand slam  that was stupid I really enjoyed it but  man what a waste of everyone's time  [Laughter]